welcome back everybody our next guests
are a pair of very talented musicians
who were recently nominated for their
seventh Grammy Award this one for best
rock performance their latest album is
called Chronicles of a diamond it's out
now say hello to black Pumas Eric Burton
and
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
well first of all it is so cool to have
you on the show you're so gifted like
the production of what you do the vocals
are insane like crazy rock and roll yeah
like it's always I am such a fan of both
of you so congratulations on your
success thank you KK but I have to say
I'm a Texas girl I heard the Austin
Texas just you have a day there's a
black Pumas day now right yeah do we
remember CU we weren't so we weren't
there when uh when when they did that
for us I think that was um on the is it
May the 7th it might be May 7th may we
do have a day the mayor gave us a day
I'm just saying there are a lot of
musicians in Austin Texas like you know
that's a huge pull of like artists like
that was pretty cool it was amazing yeah
yeah they treat us so well and we got
our own beer we got our own day oh well
you knowum is a very sounds like an
awesome beer it feels ni I don't even
like beer it's drink it's a really good
beer it's called black Pumas um did you
feel pressure the sophomore pressure you
know the sophomore album that everybody
always talks about yeah man I mean it
was just an impossible it's always an
impossible thing to do record um the
sophomore album but I think that in
experiencing the heaviness around that
um you just kind of uh heed to your own
your own soul you know you remember what
makes you beautiful and Brilliant and
you know what you're moved by so you
know we we had no choice other than um
to be moved by you know our ourselves so
we had a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
let's talk about the song You're
performing so and you're nominated for
again obviously Grammy thank you
congratulations but it's more than a
love song this song is so cool for so
many reasons I hope you win um it starts
out in this one place production wise
vocally and then it goes to almost like
this preachy kind of like talk like it's
it there's so many things going on in
this song and somehow it all is cohesive
and it flows how did you come up with
this song there's so many different
parts of the song for me we started
working on this immediately after so we
kind of never really stopped working you
know basically the record label tells us
we need to we need finish an album you
know but we started working on that
immediately after the first album and um
it was an idea we had kicking around and
it was a it was a beautiful concept that
Eric's uncle had told him this concept
of life is more than a love song and
I'll let him elaborate but yeah that one
really because we started working on it
so long ago we then started playing it
live we played it live for a couple
years and the arrangement morphed with
the live show you know that whole like
kind of gospel thing at the end yeah was
something that came out of Eric starting
to do that with the crowd and we were
able to then go back and reincorporate
that into the into the actual recording
it's brilliant it's lyrical concept that
he had that that worked with it you know
um we're a band that uh really has uh a
lot of creative freedom to that's do
what we want to do do what moves us so
yeah man CU that's almost your thing so
like why would you limit why would you
limit that that power in Ence you know
what I'm saying like it's G anyway it's
so great no one sounds like y all it's
incredible now performing more than a
love song from their new album
Chronicles of a diamond put your hands
together for black
[Applause]
Pumas
one more
[Music]
time see the two black birds
fly
[Music]
like
together when we Face the
music might help get to the other side a
Great Divine let lie
together I've asked the grand Master why
I've asked
him life is so hard some
sometimes we got to use
Music sweet show music reite your soul
to reignite your soul is
more song More Than a
fantasy more than a
little that is
more than a dream y'all it's more than a
fantasy more than
a to take your
time
help
up up
high together
now you see the two Blues Birds you sing
this
song
my respects to the Grand
Master for
theel is more more than a love song it's
more than a
fantasy more than a
little is
more dream it's more than a
[Music]
fantasy it's laugh is
more a love song it's more than a
fanty a
littleit I'm through the door now I see
the
[Music]
[Applause]
sunsh a little
bit now that through the door let's take
our time and fly some more let us fly
together now orever forever forever
forever hold your peace and
sing pretty Melodies help me get along
and sing that song
[Music]
we fly
together when the rain starts to fall
you hear the thunder sound listen to you
in the child
fly fly together fly together fly
together fly together fly together touch
that Sky together now together just fly
together fly together fly together fly
together
now together
now
ALB Chronicles of the diamond is out now
and if you want a chance to see them at
this year's Grammy Awards live and in
person head to our show's Instagram to
enter to win a pair of tickets I'm gon
be there too with my son as my date
we'll be right back with what I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
liking
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home